they live under one roof eat and work
together
Elias David and pastor Jared Maya are
all Christians and pastor Meyer wants to
help his fellow Christians he's given
them sanctuary in his church Elias and
David are two among thousands of
refugees in Germany who face deportation
I know we can't help all of these people
there are only a few we can assist the
great bulk of them pass us by large
numbers on television and those who
drown in the Mediterranean remain
nameless refugees we can only support
those we meet face to face in sanctuary
David and Elias have spent most of their
time in the parish hall they're using
much of that time to learn German Elias
and David share a room this is my bed
and that's kind of to me and do you
sometimes miss your families yeah yes I
miss my family my mother and father and
reading and David yeah yeah yes I have
my father but no family anymore my
mother's gone fake
that the loggia this is good
hello does is minor family minor father
I said a movie ended L is Liana chavista
Elias here on the left fled his home
country of Eritrea three years ago his
seven sisters and brothers fled with him
they now live dispersed all over Europe
one brother didn't survive the journey
he drowned with 500 other people in the
Mediterranean
that's a fool after I split up yeah
David is 22 just as old as Elias but
much more introverted every day he works
for the parish clerk in a church in
toasted near Hamburg his friend
Christian helps him he too is a migrant
but he's already been recognized as an
asylum seeker that means he can move
about freely and he's David's link to
the outside he brings him food and
tobacco David's situation is precarious
because German asylum law is complicated
only here on church property is he
currently safe from deportation the
church says David has a right to
sanctuary
despite help from the parish it's
distressing with this figure so I think
it's good that at least he can do
something out here in the churchyard
because I could not imagine him just
sitting inside four walls
it'll be like imprisonment yet
good morning this walkway is their
border even though the police could
arrest him here on the church side he's
left in peace as his friend Cristian
explains nca not yeah so most a time
when we are working and we have to go to
the church to clean the chairs and the
tables the police is always watching
sometimes I feel so afraid I think about
him you know any time we are coming here
I always pray to God that nothing
happens because the police is always
going and coming and going and coming
I really feel afraid for him too we
asked David if Christian takes good care
of him he tells us his friend is very
caring
David believes God has brought him here
from South Sudan to toss Ted in northern
Germany
hans-ulrich concer supports all the
refugees in his town not just those in
religious sanctuary he's a teacher and
although he's actually retired he knows
how important learning German is to live
in this country so he's teaching again
his pupils among them Elias are highly
motivated but no one knows how long
they'll be allowed to stay everyone here
knows the German word for fingerprint as
soon as they get to Europe the migrants
are fingerprinted but hardly any arrived
directly in Germany many are registered
in Italy Spain or Bulgaria that means
many faced deportation to those so
called safe third countries disaster
when you see what it does to individual
people when you see what the refugees
here have gone through this bureaucratic
regulation is sometimes completely
incomprehensible I don't know how you
can justify it how you can
cold-heartedly subject people to these
bureaucratic conditions
let's fortress Europe letting nobody in
it's an hard to bear any mother Angela
Sanford
time and again hans-ulrich consist
people's are snatched away from him this
week it's Boris on a Syrian who'll be
deported to Bulgaria pastor Meyer has to
shelter the refugees for at least six
months for their asylum applications to
be processed in Germany legally they
have no protection but the police would
never storm a church the German interior
minister has sharply criticized
sanctuary saying the church is placing
itself above the law but pastor Meyer
says this controversial step is a simple
necessity it's not about taking a
political position or political action
it's about acting for people who are in
need here who are threatened with
deportation I assume that in the
countries they'd go to without the help
to get here they could not exist for me
that's my motivation for supporting
these refugees here
the congregation is also annoyed at the
interior minister because he declared
church sanctuary to be as illegal as
Sharia Islamic law but that accusation
has made them defiant for the first time
they're publicizing their sanctuary it's
good for as many people as possible to
know that church sanctuary exists but
also that there are only about 200 in
Germany and it's completely
disproportionate to turn it into a
political debate if you've ever had
contact with refugees or spoken to them
once you lose your fears worries and
negative preconceptions right away
they're just gone everyone here is
surprised at the extent of the debate in
the two hundred church sanctuaries
throughout Germany only about 400
refugees have found protection in
contrast last year more than 10,000 were
deported
once a week congregation members get
together with David and Elias they talk
cook and eat together
yeah-hoo-hoo made the soup and peeled
the potatoes the meeting offers the
refugees another opportunity to practice
speaking German deserves a thank you but
one question still looms today what will
happen to the refugees unfortunately I
can't look into the future but I hope
they're on the right path here
I hope they can stay here where they've
begun to integrate themselves and learn
the language and they've made friends as
you can see I hope there's a future for
both of them good future is that they
can make something of the congregation
hopes the refugees won't have to go back
to Italy or Spain where they'd have to
go begging to survive that's why they're
continuing to resist and challenge
German asylum law but although more and
more parishes in Germany are doing the
same church sanctuary remains an
exception it's a small signal of help in
times when rejection of refugees has
grown in Germany
every Sunday they all gather for the
Lutheran service David and Elias they're
friends from the refugee center and
their supporters from the congregation
living together in the parish has been
productive entrusted by granting
sanctuary pastor Meyer has brought
people together and given Elias hope
again sanctuary in the church has
increased his and David's chances of
building a future in Germany